et
je vais bien
mais
c'était la voix du jazz l'une des plus
belles voix d'amériques elle la file
gerald s'était éteinte à 60 18 ans les
dernières années de sa vie avaient été
marquées par de graves ennuis de santé
nous évoquerons son souvenir à la fin de
ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir avant de revenir
dans un instant sur le match de l'équipe
de france de football dans l'euro 96
contre l'espagne et le match nul 1
partout
l'attentât de manchester une camionnette
piégée a explosé en fin matinée près du
plus grand centre commercial de la ville
la police avait été prévenue et la zone
évacuée mais latente a quand même fait
deux cent six blessés dont sept graves
sur place le reportage de notre envoyé
spécial bernard lebrun une ville
bombardée en plein coeur voici l'état de
croo street après l'explosion petite rue
où était stationnée la fourgonnette
piégée en plein centre-ville stationner
ici pour tuer tout à côté tarn d'elle
center le plus grand centre commercial
de manchester
pour une fois il faisait très beau ce
matin et les badauds se pressaient par
centaines dans les rues pour faire leurs
courses et profite de ce samedi en
solide
samedi noir samedi sombre il était ici
on sort fin lorsqu'une très violente
explosion à semer la panique et la peur
dans la ville selon les derniers bilans
206 personnes au total auraient été
blessées sept grièvement à la tête dont
une maman enceinte qui a été soufflé par
l'explosion
une soixantaine d'autres personnes
souffrent surtout de coupures provoquées
par les bris de verre ont été évacués
vers les hôpitaux
voyez ces images enregistrées moins
d'une demi heure après l'explosion les
gens courant dans tous les sens et les
cabines téléphoniques prises d'assaut
pour dire aux proches que tout va bien
au même moment à londres john médor
sortait de damien sery pour condamner ce
nouvel attentat
d'emblée le premier ministre affirme que
selon toute vraisemblance il semble être
l'oeuvre de l'armée républicaine
irlandaise fortes présomptions en effet
car comme pour l'attentât des tops lance
le 9 février dernier qui avait fait deux
morts et 100 blessés
un coup de fil anonyme à la télévision
locale de manchester a prévenu de
l'imminence de l'explosion
signature parce que caractéristiques des
méthodes employées par l'iran à belfast
gerry adams a refusé de condamner ce
septième attentat depuis la rupture du
cessez-le-feu tout en s'engageant pour
la première fois à agir sur les graves
pour qu'il soit rétabli une armée
républicaine irlandaise qui comme le
craignaient les forces de sécurité a
saisi l'occasion de l'euro 96 et la
présence de milliers de journalistes
étrangers pour faire un coup d'éclat en
frappant ici à manchester capitale
incontestée du football anglais alors
bernard lebrun vous lisiez l'instant
premier ministre john major a clairement
désigné dira même s'il n'y a pas pour
l'instant de revendications absolument
il n'y a toujours pas de revendication
mais il est vrai que l'attentât apparaît
tout à fait signer vous savez cet après
midi nous avons pu joindre au téléphone
la personne qui a reçu le coup de fil
anonyme prévenant 40 minutes exactement
à valence avant l'attentât de
l'imminence de cette explosion
et qu'est ce qu'il nous dit eh bien nous
dit que son interlocuteur avait un très
fort accent irlandais et que qui plus
est et surtout il a utilisé les codes de
l'ira pour valider son information qui
était destiné bien sûr à la police merci
bernard et on peut dire que à manchester
justement était prévu donc demain match
entre l'allemagne et la russie ce match
au rap
un lieu malgré ces attentats et ces
menaces qui persistent retour donc sur
le football maintenant la france a frôlé
la qualification tout à l'heure avant de
concéder le match nul le face à
l'espagne 1 partout avant de retourner à
leeds le film du match avec florent
gautreau tout avait bien commencé avec
cette ambiance de corrida en plein nord
de l'angleterre du soleil du bruit et
beaucoup de tension premières
banderilles et premier carton pour luis
enrique qui confond la tête de lizarazu
avec le bal au premier frisson pour les
français avec la chute de caminero dans
la surface mais l'arbitré a tout vu il
n'y avait pas penalty
alors les bleus qui jouent en blanc vont
bousculer les rouges avec le détail d'un
quatuor bien accorder djorkaeff karembeu
locaux pour guérin la frappe du parisien
est détournée en corner par zoobizarre
état à la demi heure de jeu
zidane enroule bien sa frappe mais ça
passe à côté 0 0 à la mi temps
il avait fallu 20 minutes aux hommes de
jacques et pour prendre la mesure des
roumains 48 minutes ont été nécessaires
ce soir juste après la pause 42 réalise
l'ouverture parfaite et djorkaeff trompe
tout bizarre et à la france mène 1 0
l'enchaînement contrôle frappe est
superbe
à ce moment du match la france est
qualifiée les espagnols font tout pour
revenir mais l'ama est impérial devant
certes j tout d'abord puis sur cette
frappe de caminero
les français croient tenir leur
qualification mais à six minutes de la
fin l'espagne trouve la faille caminero
reprend de volée et marque
l'ama a bien touché le ballon mais c'est
insuffisant
l'espagne sauve sa peau in extremis les
deux équipes invaincues depuis deux ans
n'ont pas pu se départager
les français eux regretteront longtemps
les contres manqué de la deuxième mi
temps ils ont tout fait pour éviter cela
mais tout se jouera contre la bulgarie
alors disons petite alice retrouvé il ya
de la voix aimé jacquet bonsoir mais
sûrement n'a pas le choix on est passés
à côté d'une belle occasion quand même
ce soir c'est vrai aimez votre équipe
était qualifié pour les quarts de finale
à seulement cinq minutes de la fin du
match on l'a vu et m et méritait
amplement la qualification nous avons
sûrement réaliser une des plus belles
prestations depuis je suis le
sélectionneur de cette équipe de france
nous avions bien mesurer la qualité de
cet adversaire et nous n'avons
manifestement bien manoeuvré bon il ya
eu un petit peu de une faute de
communication sur cette égalisation mais
il ya surtout un déchet sur le plan
percussions finition nous aurions très
bien pu marquer un deuxième but dans
diverses occasions
est ce qu'on peut parler aussi de
fatigue il est vrai que vous avez fait
rentrer trois joueurs pendant le match
et notamment vous avez renforcer le
secteur défensif
à vingt minutes de la fin ça a pas suffi
c'est pas c'est gagner le football c'est
se mettre en disposition n'est pas
fatigué pas de tactique c'est c'est de
mettre les gens dans les meilleures
conditions c'est ce que je fais depuis
deux ans je pense que là ça a été un
petit relâchement des fois ça fait
partie du foot
ça veut dire que à l'horizon points
l'équipe de bulgarie qui nous rappelle
de si mauvais souvenir et contre
laquelle il faudra obtenir la cage la
qualification pour les quarts devant
tous les matchs ça fait deux ans que ça
dure on continuera on n'irait pas blake
ile-de-france de la qualité là des
joueurs de talent eh bien on va
poursuivre notre chemin dans la trique
tranquillité et la sérénité
mais on vous retrouve dans trois jours
alors à mes yeux merci est la voix et
mercier aimé jacquet bien sûr on suivra
ce match mardi 18 juin entre la france
et la bulgarie le match de la
qualification l'espère encore un mot de
football avec dans le groupe à la
victoire sans grand panache de
l'angleterre sur l'ecosse
but à 0 deux buts inscrits en deuxième
mi temps par cher et gascogne après que
les écossais eut raté un penalty avec
cette victoire l'angleterre est
maintenant en tête de son groupe avec
les pays bas
voilà le très beau but de gascogne
deuxième but de l'angleterre
en allemagne le plan d'austérité du ch
en sus les deux du chancelier kohl
mobilise les salariés ils étaient 350
milles dans les rues de bonnes cet après
midi à l'appel de la puissante
confédération allemande des syndicats
jérôme cathala ils sont arrivés à bonn
par train ou car spéciaux venus de toute
l'allemagne
à l'appel de la dgb la confédération des
syndicats qui regroupe 9 millions
d'adhérents
résultat quand les différents défilés se
sont rejoint les manifestants étaient à
peu près 350 milles c'est à dire plus
que la population totale de la ville de
bonnes cibles de leurs critiques
le chancelier kohl et son gouvernement
dans le programme d'austérité prévoit de
limiter les hausses de salaire mais
aussi les allocations maladie et
différentes prestations sociales le tout
afin d'économiser près de 200 millions
de francs ce plan est un catalogue de
cruauté d'injustice sociale a dit le
chef de la confédération des syndicats
guetteur schulte ajoutant si le
gouvernement veut le conflit il l'aura
bref voilà lancé une menace de grève
générale à la française comme disent les
syndicalistes allemands en référence au
mouvement de décembre dernier une menace
rare dans un pays qui a si longtemps
vécu sous le règne du consensus social
cette manifestation en tout cas était la
plus importante de l'après guerre
et aux etats unis la maison blanche se
trouve confronté à une affaire pour le
moins embarrassante elle s'est procurée
auprès du fbi aille plus de 400 fiches
de renseignements confidentiels sur des
opposants du parti républicain une
erreur administrative selon bill clinton
le président américain une violation
extrêmement grave de la vie privée selon
le patron du fbi à la campagne
électorale est terminée en russie pour
ses premières élections d'un chef de
l'état dans l'histoire de la russie elle
signer son adversaire communiste
guennadi ziouganov sont au coude à coude
dans les derniers sondages sur place à
moscou dominique derda s'il suffit d'un
peu de pluie pour rendre les mariages
heureux alors à coup sûr celui ci le
sera
en cette veille d'élection déjà grisé
par quelques toasts
les jeunes époux ont sans doute affiche
dans l'avenir une confiance certaine il
y en a beaucoup qui vont voter joguin 9
mai pour l seen on sera plus nombreux
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est mieux que
ce qu'ils avaient hier tous les sondages
indiquent pourtant que face à zoug à
neuf le candidat communiste
la partie s'annonce difficile pour
l'actuel locataire du kremlin
jirinovski lui une fois encore pourrait
bien créer la surprise et jouer les
arbitres au second tour on sent dans la
rue est une véritable tension
les gens sont inquiets ils s'attendent à
quelque chose des changements
elle n'est sans doute pas la seule à
craindre que quelque chose ne se
produise la police elle aussi à
renforcer la surveillance dans tous les
lieux publics sur les marchés d'une gare
à 10 mètres de là cette vieille dame
pour survivre vent les pivoines de son
jardin de sa jeunesse elle ne se
souvient que des moments heureux
elle votera zoug en oeuvre comme
beaucoup de retraités alors parce qu'ils
sont moins enclins à voter communiste
pour convaincre les jeunes de se rendre
aux urnes dans ce bureau de vote voisins
d'un casino on leur offrira en
remerciement du devoir accompli une
belle boîte de chocolats mais puisqu'il
ne faut jurer de rien dans cette
imprévisible russie on dépoussière à
tout hasard les idoles d'un passé qui
dimanche pourrait bien renaître de ses
cendres au nez et à la barbe de ceux qui
le croyaient enterré à jamais et en
tchétchénie où les opérations de vote
ont déjà commencé la participation est
très faible à grozny trois bureaux de
vote ont été la cible d'attentats la
nuit dernière ces élections sur
constesté vous le savez par les
indépendantistes tchétchènes
en france ils étaient cinq à dix mille
dans les rues de paris pour protester
contre les lois pasqua sur l'immigration
et le renforcement éventuel par jean
louis debré une manifestation à l'appel
de 70 associations partis politiques ou
syndicats d'autres rassemblements du
même type se sont produits en province
de coude immigrés en situation régulière
ou pas se disent inquiets et des projets
fret le gouvernement en matière de lutte
contre l'immigration
même si alain juppé hier a précisé
qu'aucune décision n'était encore arrêté
dans ce domaine demain michèle cotta
consacrera son émission à la polémique
sur les villes qui interdisent la
mendicité des décisions jugées indignes
et par xavier emmanuelli de secrétaires
d'état à l'action humanitaire qui sera
sur le plateau de polémique en marge
d'une réunion publique à châteauvallon
près de toulon françois léotard le
président de l'udf s'en est pris très
vertement à l'entourage de jean marie le
pen dont certains at il dit on était des
collaborateurs du régime de vichy et des
nazis nous l'écoutons
pourquoi et comment monsieur le pen at
il pu s'entourer dans les dernières
années jusqu'à aujourd'hui de gens qui
ont été des collaborateurs et pour
certains d'entre eux des actifs
collaborateurs des nazis
vous pensez à qui victor barthélémy qui
était le bras droit de jacques doriot et
qui a été un des amis intimes et
personnels de monsieur le pen et qui a
contribué à la constitution du front
national je pense à andré dufraisse qui
a été combattre sous les couleurs de la
wehrmacht en ukraine et je pense à paul
malades du team qui est actuellement
conseiller régional dans la région
centre et qui étaient associés comme
vous le savez à la tuerie de la vie la
mort fleuri au moment de la libération
de cannes
alors il faut bien qu'on dise les choses
il faut pas que monsieur le pen parle
des vertus nationale quand il s'est
entouré de gens qui ont combattu sous
l'uniforme allemand contre les forces
françaises
je crois qu'il faut dire les choses donc
voilà les propos de françois léotard et
comme prévu le groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale a déposé
aujourd'hui une motion de censure contre
le gouvernement une motion qui devrait
être débattu la semaine prochaine en
bretagne l'incendié qui a ravagé pendant
trois jours une partie des monts d'arrée
est désormais maîtrisée l'heure est
maintenant au bilan de ce sinistre qui a
provoqué d'importants dégâts sur la
faune et la flore de ce parc
rés
chenal jérôme laurent et gabriel camilla
il tente de se cacher des hommes comme
si la lande existait encore complètement
isolés au milieu des terres brûlées se
fend de chevreuil a perdu sa mère dans
l' incendie des monts d'arrée il ya des
flammes depuis 4 5 mètres de haut qui
surgissait de la l'ombre donc la plupart
des animaux terrestres ont été
littéralement encerclé avec les oiseaux
adultes qui ont puissante et denis
flotter l'ornithologue du parc régional
d'armorique pour lui comme pour les
écologistes de la région
l'incendié a causé des ravages
d'irréparable notamment chez les oiseaux
certaines espèces protégées comme le
courlis ou le busard cendré était en
pleine édification et c'est un petit
aigle un petit aigle chasseur de
serpents là le cirque est très très rare
ici au nord de la loire et là bas il se
nourrit serpent mais bon on peut être
sûr que la plupart des serpents ont
veillé qui va avoir beaucoup de mal à à
se nourrir et va être obligé de tourner
sur des zones beaucoup plus plus
éloignés quoi le paysage a également
souffert près de 500 hectares de bruyère
et de fleurs sauvages ont été calcinés
c'est d'autant plus rageant que
l'origine de ce sinistre aurait très
bien pu être évité c'est le mauvais
fonctionnement d'un fumigènes utilisés
au cours de manoeuvres militaires qui a
déclenché un incendie le milieu si qui
arrivera à terme et il va falloir des
années pour retrouver le même type de
milieu que ce qu'on a que ce qu'on a
connu
et puis bah ça va poser le problème de
le gérer pour éviter que ça se
reproduise tous les dix ans suite à des
manoeuvres militaires ou d'autres
d'autres folies déjà en 1976 une partie
de ses landes avait été ravagé par un
incendie
vingt ans plus tard les mandats répète à
nouveau un lourd tribut au feu une
nouvelle fois à cause de l'imprudence
des hommes arianespace sera sur onze
jours après l'échec d'ariane 5 le 87e
lancement d'ariane 4 s'est déroulée lui
sans incident à kourou en guyane
un tir réussi à 8h55 ce matin heure
française pour la mise en orbite d'un
satellite de télécommunications de 305
intelsat 709 voilà par ariane qui
s'élève ariane 4 en france selon le
rapport sur la loi de programmation
militaire le nombre des hélicoptères de
l'armée de terre sera réduit de moitié
d'ici 2002 et puis à propos de la
nouvelle taxe prévue sur les stations
essence des grandes surfaces pour aider
les petits pompistes indépendants
le ministre délégué aux finances estime
qu'elle ne devrait pas faire remonter le
prix de l'essence
sachez enfin que plusieurs milliers
d'homosexuels ont défilé à toulouse lyon
et lille pour réclamer l'égalité des
droits et rappelé la nécessité de lutter
contre le sida
retour au sport maintenant avec les 24
heures du mans les porsche se sont
distingués d'entrée de jeu qu'en est il
maintenant après six heures de course
laurent tribolet effectivement benoît le
soleil est en train de se coucher sur le
monde en ait un peu plus de six heures
de course et un quart de la distance est
effectivement les porsche domine avant
de vous préciser ça exactement jour
oppose juste une image traditionnelle on
peut pas la rater
c'est le départ il a été donnée tout à
l'heure à 15 heures c'est quand même
l'image traditionnelle du 24 heures du
mans il y à des stars sur la piste comme
mario andretti
il ya des stars en dehors de la piste
comme alain delon qui a donné le départ
il ya 48 équipages qui s'en donnent à
coeur joie si tôt donc le drapeau baiser
48 équipages ça fait donc cent quarante
quatre pilotes qui vont en découdre
pendant 24 heures à environ un peu plus
de 200 km heure de moyenne
alors benoît on en revient donc au
classement actuellement après donc un
peu six heures de cours je vous propose
d'aller voir tout de suite les images du
direct et vous allez voir effectivement
il ya déjà quelques phare qui se sont
allumés c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et voici la voiture de tête c'est une
geste numéro 7 et allemands une force
c'est pas tout à fait une porsche enfin
il y a un lien avec porsche
elle est pilotée par l'équipage reuter
jones murs ou les connaissais pas très
bien
en revanche vous connaissez mieux ceux
qui sont en deuxième position une
porsche officielle pilotée par bout de
scène wollek hejduk ensuite on trouve
une autre porsche officielle et ensuite
lente rogers
donc vous voyez où quatre premières
places c'est quasiment un monopole de
porsche dans l'eau dans le haut du
classement à ses 64 24 heures du mans
voilà merci beaucoup laurent tribolet
donc on voit plus mais vous visiez et
qu'il n'y a toujours pas depuis il
devrait pas y en avoir cette pluie sur
sur le mans et puis au grand prix de
formule un du canada c'est le
britannique damon hill qui partira en
pole position demain sur le circuit
gilles-villeneuve aux côtés de jacques
villeneuve sur williams renault
c'était je vous le disais l'une des plus
grandes solistes du jazz l'une des plus
belles voix d'amériques la fitzgerald
s'est éteint dans sa maison de beverly
hills en californie elle avait 78 ans à
la fin de sa vie est là gérald avait
connu de graves problèmes de santé après
une opération à coeur ouvert elle avait
dû être amputé des deux jambes en raison
de complications dues au diabète
eric père
but as bagard à calais
moi
à
les blues à l'opérette du jazz le plus
avant aux tubes les plus populaires ella
fitzgerald excellé dans tous les
domaines
né en 1918 elle a 16 ans lorsqu'elle est
remarqué par le batteur site web lors
d'un concours amateur la first lady of
jazz la première dame du jazz et nec à
la tête d'un big band puis en carrière
solo vedette des fabuleux cession de
norman grant jazz radio philharmonie qu
elle prendra sa voix auprès des plus
grands grâce à son swing naturel à la
suite rats dur pour le grand public les
trous valent parfois difficile des
novateurs
elle fera beaucoup pour le be bop de
dizzy gillespie ou de charlie parker
embrassades de 40 daisy baiser du duke
ellington qui composera pour elle une
oeuvre dont l'un des mouvements
s'intitule viande catégorie hors norme
et puis bien sûr louis armstrong avec
qui elle créera notamment un port
guillaume besse mémorable glissant
scandale ni drogue
ella fitzgerald ne jouait pas la star sa
spontanéité était sa sagesse
sainte marie
non
considéré aux états unis comme un trésor
national elle a été récompensé de
nombreuses fois 1989 elle recevait son
13e grammy awards
déjà affaiblies et quasiment aveugle
mais toujours cette voix
une puissance qui ferait presque oublier
sa fragilité physique
hewson
d'une fidélité exemplaire au texte ella
fitzgerald et est experte dans l'art de
découvrir les trésors cachés d'une
chanson qu'aucun autre interprète
n'avait deviner
youtube
et
weight
elle avait le don de suspendre le temps
elle avait la voix pour parler aux
femmes elles la voient la fin de cette
édition merci d'avoir suivi dans un dans
un instant la météo laurent romejko nous
allons encore du soleil vers une heure
du matin l'édition de la nuit avec
florence dauchez à 7 heures demain matin
thé ou café catherine ceylac je vous
retrouverai bien sûr demain à 13h et je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée avec
arthur sur france